The Joe Rogan Experience but anyway
let's let's take a look at this [__]
hoarder
um
you ready am I ready no one's ready
never
I'm the only one I think who thinks this
is hilarious okay how we blur this out I
think I'm just gonna not show it because
it's known as like yeah
don't show it don't show it just show uh
Shane's face ladies uh distractions
[__] in bottles
oh boy for a decade oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God here's the
best part that's the lady oh my God
there's [__] everywhere
she that's her [__] bucket yeah
watch that's her [__] bucket and then
she's like sometimes it gets too heavy
so I have to transfer buckets nice bro I
can't do this hold on I can't do this oh
my god dude shut the [__] up she lives
in a [__] house
look at that [__] everywhere dude oh my
God I'm gonna throw up
[__]
[Music]
what the [__] man so this is the
interview here she goes she goes I can't
be the worst hoarder you've ever seen
but they're like look at this side it
says I am okay yeah
[Music]
they're okay no because I thought it was
due to the mold and dust you have to
tell me this because I I you don't know
yeah I mean some people would argue how
do you not know that
but wait I don't smell it anymore it's
extremely dangerous okay stop stop stop
stop I will [__] throw it she's so
matter of fact the entire time like the
entire time people like she's like yeah
there's mold in the walls that's why it
smells like that and they're like are
you sure it's not the feces bottles of
feces and urine everywhere and she's
like what
no that can't be it like no that's
definitely it she's like well that's
news to me imagine if this was fake and
then they conned us and that's like
chocolate milk and they didn't take the
paper you can tell this lady's gone
maybe she's like a really good actress
okay
dude so at the very end at the very end
this is this is the best part so at the
very end they're like we're gonna have
to uh uh we gotta go in there and clear
out all the all the stuff in there so
all her food's contaminated she doesn't
her she doesn't have her refrigerator
she says bread on the ground that's
covered in mold at one point they're
like you can't eat that moldy bread
she's like I'm gonna take the [__]
mold off obviously all right at the very
end they're like poop everywhere [__]
everywhere dude what do you think her
like digestive tract is like she's
eating Progressive soup with [__] in
here she's eating nothing but soup
because you you get a certain amount of
[__]
bottles dude yeah you know when they
swab things they find like human fecal
matter on things all the time like
doorknobs and stuff so like you're if
you eat a chip after you touch a
doorknob there's some fecal matter
probably that gets in there this lady's
eating all right so at the very end
they're like we gotta go in there and uh
she's like hold on
let me get one more night I'm gonna go
ahead back in there and eat some
contaminated food and they're like and
then she goes and then the party's over
like
you mean a part what do you
you think it's a party to eat
contaminated food she's like what do you
guys [__] care I've been anything
I've been in there eating poop for 12
years
what the [__] hold up will you get to
that part of the very end dude the dude
what like she says it she goes what do
you care I've been eating poop for 12
years as soon as she says he goes oh
like just watching the dude get defeated
by a lady
I'm trying to explain this properly
the music they played dramatic music she
goes what are you guys [__] care and
he goes he looks at it she goes I've
been in there eating poop for 12 years
and he goes
she takes the guy's Soul dude hold on
[__] I'm trying to find it it's right
it's towards the very end they're giving
her basically the intervention it's two
people outside it's a lady and the guy
imagine your brain yes yes I'm gonna go
ahead back in there
it's gonna be hard but I'm gonna give up
some stuff
this guy and I I'm going to go ahead and
eat some of the contaminated food and
then the party's over because I have to
get it because when somebody goes on
Intervention they want to get high one
last time the party ends for me tomorrow
how is eating contaminated food a party
I'm why does it matter I've been eating
poop for 12 years
reality
I don't think it's fake
but I've been fooled before
true
that's how it works it seems like if
you're unless she's wearing Prosthetics
it seems like there's
she it seems like she's suffering the
effects of her poor diet like dude the
inflammation in her face from pooping at
the end dude at the end they bulldoze
the house and put in an assisted living
room it's not like a happy ending of
Hoarders oh my God so the houses it's
beyond conditions the city you had to
get involved and destroy the land
I just salt the Earth that's so insane
it's pretty fun though just a lady and
her mom [__] in a bucket before that
what was the worst one the lady who eats
toilet paper remember that lady uh did
you ever see the lady who eats toilet
paper that was uh my sick addiction or
whatever is that what it was it's one of
those
I didn't I never even watched it I
watched this hoarders I never watched
hoarders yeah she was just chewing up
toilet paper and she said it was
addictive no there was a lady the worst
the second worst hoarders is a lady who
had like 90 dead cats in her house oh
God and she was saving them she was
putting them in the fridge she was like
I don't want to say goodbye to these
guys
takes them out for the camera
eyes are deteriorated
dude rat Collection watch this guy at
the beginning he goes oh boy uh he's
like yeah people try to talk about it
but until you tried it for yourself or
something like that what don't knock it
till you try it he has a million rats
well you know there's like a temple in
India where rats are have you ever see
that rat temple in India no oh dude this
is wild so this is a temple in India and
these rats all hang out with everyone
they eat with you they they like leave
the rats they put milk out for them the
rats are all drinking milk they'll they
all like share yeah it's the weirdest
thing it's like a temple filled with
rats so as these people are all praying
like dude rats are everywhere everywhere
but they're not treated poorly well they
got this wrong but this really weird man
because this is like look the rats just
like eat their food
and it's this beautiful Temple let's see
what this guy does this guy have an
explanation no Emily is here let's see
what he says when they die they're born
as rats when a rat dies it's born as us
humans
that might seem Preposterous to many in
the west so they're just chilling people
here
if they die and become a rat yeah
but they've managed to create an
environment where they live with rats
yeah well there's gonna be a new [__]
plague if these guys keep doing this or
not they better knock it off seems like
it's working fine
maybe that's how you avoid a play I bet
these dudes get viciously ill constantly
as they get bro Indian food and raped
all day they're [__] all over the
place that's the thing I was like oh
it's peaceful no it's rat chick no yeah
you 100 get rat [__] everywhere
but what if they're right dude
with you and me wake up rat your rat
dude why do some guys giving you milk